a partner from back in the day of
Thursday Night Football on NFL Network
he is Brad Nessler how you been Brett
Friends of two former networks right bud
that's true
[Laughter]
I miss you too Brad I miss you certainly
those chats and conversations we would
have in the I'm doing great thank you
how's everything with you with the SEC
how you've enjoined that season probably
never enjoyed anything more than this
rich you know was away from it for eight
weeks last year and realized how much I
love this game and and love doing what I
do and so when you're away from it you
lose it for a minute and you get it back
you appreciate everything that much more
and so it's been it's been unbelievable
being back with Gary and at CBS and our
games questionable at times so far this
year well I'll tell you what it seems to
be very top-heavy in the SEC to say the
least but Alice you taking on Alabama
this week LSU which was struggling
earlier now has cracked the top 20 again
give me give me give me your thoughts on
how LSU can shock the world a little bit
yeah I don't know they can't or not but
I think one of the best things that
could happen to him was losing to Troy
they just were disorganized they weren't
focused that got their heads back on
straight I think in coach Oh got him
had it in the right direction they're
you know they're talented they're not
LSU past years talented because they're
not deep enough I don't think you know
they got some when you got Darius guys
and people like that they have great
skill position players defensively
they're maybe not quite the LSU teams of
the past and they're certainly not as
deep but you know they're playing a lot
better a month ago if you and I would
have been talking I would said Oh
wonderful we're going to do that game
even though that's you know almost a
given that LSU and Alabama is going to
play at night and CBS but a month ago it
didn't look so good now it looks a lot
better
can they shock the world I don't know if
anybody can beat Alabama and I'm kind of
surprised they're number two and be
honest with you and st. George and
Alabama each twice in person and our
cumulative scores rich are 192 14 and
one of those
one of those was the defensive touchdown
and one was Florida just trying to get
on the board so they kept their streak
alive of scoring in every game for 368
or whenever they scored it two and half
minutes left last week so those four
games have been so a lot sided that I'm
not sure its top-heavy you're right now
I know I I don't mean to laugh because
we have radio fan bases in both Florida
and Tennessee and Florida's already
moved on from its coach intestacy is
rumored to be thinking about it
themselves
now Georgia being on top of Alabama what
why would you be surprised about that
right just the eye test haven't done
both of them twice I just think Alabama
is a little bit better not a lot you
know their scores over the teams that we
saw Georgia's were just about as
lopsided I still think if somebody said
you can have Jalen Hurd so you can have
Jake prom I'm taking Jalen Hertz just
from the experience standpoint
Alabama's deeper in the back field even
though Georgia's got five guys that can
play when I've done the Alabama games
they're putting in the third string
tight end just to run the ball at the
end just to give anybody else a breather
I mean that's how good they are in the
backfield and defensively Georgia's
close I just think Alabama is better and
I guess it's just the eye test I just
think Alabama I mean I can't wait if if
those two end up squaring off in the SEC
championships gonna be a hell of a game
how they're not gonna be in front of you
for that call pardonne how in the world
will they not be in front of you for
that well yeah it should work out that
way I just think there's a lot of ball
left you know I mean Georgia's got to go
to Auburn so does Alabama Auburn you
know if they play like they did the
first half against LSU they're capable
beating anybody if they play like they
did the second half LSU they might lose
the rest of their games so I can't
figure out some of these guys but anyway
they both have to go through the plains
and that's not going to be easy for you
to one of them Brad Nessler voice of SEC
football on CBS Sports joining me here
on the Rich Eisen show I'll tell you one
person who's probably happy that Alabama
is ranked lower than Georgia Tech guest
right now suddenly it's not poison to
talk about right that's not right boys
and now it's now it's something to get
maybe to snap the attention of
it's catnip yeah that's Caleb right can
I use that one I'm supposed to be a red
I just used it our producer Ken tulu got
my ear and suggested that to me so I
want reducers are smart guys everything
they really are so Nikki's gotta like
that right right now if I'm Nick I'm
sending like four big boxes those
chocolate-covered strawberries that are
shaped like footballs I'm sending those
to North Dallas or wherever those
committee guys are right now and saying
gentlemen you just did me the biggest
favor in the world and Kirby Smart is
going why in the world did you guys do
that to me that's what I think those two
coaches are thinking right now yeah
because it's just food for thought right
now yeah I mean Notre Dame and Clemson I
mean in terms of what you've seen on on
TV then passing the with the eye test
yeah who do you think of the one wind
teams would you agree that Notre Dame
and Clemson get to go over Oklahoma Ohio
State Penn State or TCU yeah that's what
you know that's why we got four more
weeks left I think I've seen Notre Dame
let's see I saw the entire game against
Georgia I've seen them play probably two
halfs other than that and it's usually
when I'm coming back from doing my own
game
you know what the committee's kind of
done those they painted themselves in a
corner year with Notre Dame already
three what if you know Georgia goes all
the way to the SEC championship and
loses to Alabama and Notre Dame runs the
table the Notre Dame ahead of Georgia
when George already beat Notre Dame no
way man know what that's why this stuff
school for you to talk about me to talk
about and all that kind of stuff but you
know I think Clemson is really good I'm
shocked at Oklahoma lost you know bedlam
is gonna straighten some of that stuff
out too and and TCU and the Oklahoma
Oklahoma State TCU thing's gonna take
care of itself and we'll the Big Ten
take care of itself I don't know after
last year well I mean in terms of that
Brad I mean the same scenario that had
Penn State fans up in arms could be used
to put Penn State over Ohio State this
time around absolutely exactly not a
beats Wisconsin at Penn State runs the
table and you know whatever well I mean
yeah no I would say Michigan beating
Ohio State you know if I to choose one
yeah one where in your amazing
blue underwear right now you probably
take Michigan yeah you know but but but
I mean in the same way that folks were
it's interesting that the same scenario
being presented where again
Ohio State loses once more in Big Ten
competition right and Penn State wins
out yep that Ohio State would be able to
that Penn State would be able to get in
over Ohio State why not win the Big Ten
by not even going to the Big Ten
championship game right yep this end but
people are like why can't you that Ohio
staple why not last year why not you
think they'll let them have it happen
again
I'm you know I think they look back the
committee from last year and go we
messed that up I would think they did
and if if not they should and with that
in mind I don't know if they'll let that
happen again or not I don't know if I
don't know if Penn State would get would
get shut out if they got into the
national semifinal all right proper to
say that yeah I don't know what are you
laughing out over there Brock where you
think I'm trolling on Ohio State I'm not
doing that do you think you're trying
are these are facts they still haven't
scored these are facts and supposition
yeah that's true it's all I'm saying
Brad throws to chat with you look
forward to the next time already and I
do miss I do miss the the the postgame
revelry on Thursday night I'll be
watching your man's always seem hello
Marshall and moochin and Michael and
Deanna and the whole crew I said hey I
will do that you got it that's Brad
Nessler
for more Rich Eisen show tuned to
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the
doesn't show up